in vielen Ländern der Welt kann
jederzeit eine Krise ausbrechen unds
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher
Vorort in Gefahr bringen doch wir sind
gerüstet mit der Mission vorwärts des
österreichischen
Bundesheeres Mission vorwärts ist die
große Neuaufstellung des
österreichischen Bundesheeres über die
nächsten 10 Jahre werden über 16
Milliarden Euro in die Modernisierung
des bundeshahres
[Musik]
investiert die Welt um uns verändert
sich und mit ihr die Herausforderungen
denen sich unser Land stellen muss für
die Sicherheit von Österreicherinnen und
Österreichern im Ausland ist es
erforderlich sich mit einem kampffähigen
und modernen herer für jederzeit
auftretende Bedrohungslagen zu
rüsten verschärft sich die Lage in einer
Krisenregion unternehmen wir alles
um österreichische Bürger rasch in
Sicherheit zu bringen aus diesem Grund
setzen wir aktuell und in Zukunft
folgende Maßnahmen Ausbau unsere
Spezialeinsatzkräfte für
Auslandsmissionen unsere Spezialisten
sind ein perfekt eingespieltes Team im
Falle einer drohenden Gefahr für
österreichische Bürger haben sie den
Auftrag diese Reaktion schnell in
Sicherheit zu bringen dieserfdert
Fitness modernste Ausrüstung und
permanente aus und
Weiterbildung Sicherstellung der
Transportmöglichkeiten bei Ernstfällen
auch in weit entfernten Krisenregionen
müssen wir in der Lage sein die Menschen
schnell und sicher nach Hause zu bringen
und wir müssen auch für medizinische
Notfälle gerüstet
sein Stabilisierung der Region das
österreichische Bundesheer ist ein
verlässlicher Partner in internationalen
Missionen in enger Kooperation mit
unseren Partnern setzen wir zahlreiche
friedenserhaltende Maßnahmen wie etwa
die Ausbildung lokaler Einheiten vor Ort
dies hilft Krisen dort zu bekämpfen wo
sie
[Musik]
entstehen